Coover yeah why is he working by like
hydraulics and [ __ ] like why Oh
[Music]
nation it's Greg outta here I'm John
here as well
we're gonna watch today from how it
should have ended his he dubs ooh I
don't think I've seen another done
second one to Batman V Superman with
Justice League coming out yeah well
better or a movie to revisit yeah my
favorite if there's one guy who to talk
about DC it's our friend Andrew a movie
source channel source you just mentioned
the words BV yes he will tell you what
he thinks I like you
[Music]
hold down girl who did all this
[Music]
my boyfriend is gonna be so pissed at
you and you're telling the truth
yep no lives here well in that case the
US government think Superman is bad I
gotta go finish mine don't worry
I'm dangerous Superman who are you okay
[Music]
if there's even a 1% chance we're gonna
as good a time to kill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that's really tiring why don't I
check out these files they're never
bothered looking at floor they it's beef
lady well she was here like amazing
thank you let's make a monster now are
you sure this plot isn't getting too
ridiculous I think you mean crazy stupid
stupid stupid stupid they stopped
throwing my girlfriend off buildings I
was making a monster earlier but now
would you like Batman what why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
time to die well this must be your good
thanks for telling me Oh can't you just
like go get her real quick
I mean have alpha tell you where she is
you click save for two seconds
no I gotta like stop Lex Luthor okay
fine he was just mullet BAE Superman
you've lost Lex this movie should end
here it's not gonna fight my monster
baby I got five now we gotta do that
speedy here
you redress me play me again hahaha bein
saved your life
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time to unite the lead really you can
save the world
[Music]
[Music]
never seen their his e-dub second I was
really well done at first it was hard to
adjust to its pacing yeah at first it
was hard to adjust to its editing but
once it starts settling in and getting
on board with it I thought it was really
well executed man because the jokes are
all everything the screenwriters are
wanting you to think and feel at the
time yes it's very on the nose a lot
like a Cliff's Notes version of beefy
the Batman voiceover dude is so freakin
funny man especially when he's just
Bruce but he's still talking like that
yeah this is like the great blend of
like pointing out although the wacky
things about this movie while also
helping you recap just in time basically
like everything that happens that you
need to remember it's all the
significant stuff I found this his he
dubs version to be a blend of what
how should a minute already does with
cinemasins yeah yeah because they're
taking the specific scenes and you're
making fun of exactly what the
screenwriters are wanting you to think
you'll at that time remember this mom's
name is mark and also like things that
they can't point out when the guys has
this background in the cop shows up
everyone's afraid of the Batman or like
every line of like says finally we
finally learned when he sleeps and is
that OH Batman's tired that's I think
that's that's all Abed aplex that's how
Ben Affleck narrows down his Batman to
one specific thing he breaks it all down
from there just wants to go to sleep was
making fun of like what Batman's
thrashing like we're killing those guys
with his Batmobile before he bolts in a
Superman look at the images again house
looks pretty cool that yeah I forgot how
cool that that image those images looked
actually yeah yeah the only thing that
the dead man's colon movie grabbed me
about those was I was just like is he a
bad driver
I think it's distracting us Superman's
Chester pops out of a suit I always goes
to it it's like it goes to his chest and
that it goes to his chest hair why is he
working by like hydraulics and [ __ ] like
what and a veggie fly you can fly with
this movie that is always the one
whenever I watch this video girl what is
he thinking it's gonna get Jackson to
get pumped up to fight Superman do a
warm-up full-on work out nah we caught
her McGregor Mayweather gonna fight me
all right workout for like two hours
really exhausts our bodies then we'll
get sure my muscles are blown and my
biceps or by the time I make it equal
who's gonna have kryptonite I would have
not done the suit and the kryptonite
sphere if I hadn't do this workout but
since I did this workout I'm probably
gonna need some help maybe he's just a
stickler maybe that wasn't even for the
fight maybe that part of his day he
can't skip that whole Martha thing it
does bother me about that is why is Pat
man going in a scene because that's what
he does Superman could easily just got
your mom all right let me go handle this
a warehouse fight super bomb bomb bomb
is five when the coolest fights in all
comic book movies easily at the same
time though that process would have been
shorter if Superman went in here and he
still could have gotten to doomsday
introduction at the same exact time the
whole movie doesn't even make as he does
i watch I got more of these man this is
fantastic this is fantastic I have
surprised of having caught one of yours
before they had the blade record one I
want to check that out that's a good
recap for it's a great way to recap this
is basically like the blunt bullet point
yes of
folks MiG's Bank hey guys subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification bell subscribe to how it
should have ended yeah follow us on
social media and we will be checking out
Justice League late Thursday night so
expect a review for Justice League up by
Friday morning early afternoon somewhere
there thank you